[Techno Music]
[Morris] Where do you see yourself in the
future? Because I'm telling you,
that, your future is here today!
[Brennan] I'm a nurse and anindustrial engineer. Those two pieces come togetherbecause we focus on, as engineers, makingthe world better through technology
and as nurses, through using interpersonal and
medicine technologies to make people better.
[Brutus] If you have a dream, you have to protect
it and don't let anybody ever take thatdream away from you.
And this really speaks to theimportance of finding your why and understanding
that your why will be your source ofmotivation every day and it's a long journey.
[Akingbola] It is possible, even if you don'tnecessarily see it. I didn't see a black
physician growing up. Literally, we didn't have any
of my community, I didn't even have black teachers
until medical school actually it was the
first time that happened for me. So, it
is possible, even if you don't see somebody
who's representative of yourself in medicine.
[Rodriguez] It's not just one person that will help
you get to where you want or need to go,
it's a multitude of people or a village that will
help raise you into the person that you want to be.
[Perez-Stable] Remember to pay it forward, remember to be a mentorand be generous as you as you grow into into what
you want to do.
[Holden] Our goal at mentoring and medicine
is to help you become successful. The world is yourstage, just keep asking questions keep beingcurious, and you will achieve your dreams.
[Techno music swells]